blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman i know that these stories have
become exhausting but it is important to
keep them in the public spotlight
another one of these anti-vaccine
so-called christians has died of covid
and this is not just an anti-vaccine
christian
this is someone who was pushing
ivermectin and pushing
hydroxychloroquine the new york times
reports that marcus lam a christian
broadcaster and vaccine skeptic has died
of covid
this was the co-founder of the daystar
television network over the years we've
played lots of wacky clips of
non-empirically based claims from shows
on the daystar network
marcus lamb christian broadcaster in
dallas dismissive of covet vaccinations
died tuesday after contracting the virus
mr lam was 64.
frequently suggested on his christian tv
network that people pray instead of
getting inoculated
he had to be rushed to the hospital when
his oxygen levels dropped quote all of a
sudden
after he contracted the virus
mr lam's wife and son confirmed his
death on tuesday on ministry now
the show the couple hosted
it was not immediately clear when he
tested positive or where he died
the network did not respond to requests
for comment
he
hosted a bunch of different shows
daystar broadcasters including the lambs
repeatedly questioned the efficacy of
the vaccine on may 10th they said that
the vaccine could be killing your immune
system that's false
we want to warn you we want to help you
we'll want to give you an alternative
what was the alternative well instead of
get getting vaccinated quote we can pray
we can get ivermectin
and budesinide
and hydroxychloroquine those drugs are
not approved for covet treatment by the
fda
he also denounced vaccination mandates
for school children on november 18th
ms lam said her husband contracted the
virus after she had he had diabetes
which exacerbated his symptoms
last month jonathan lamb the son said
his father's coveted battle was the
result of a spiritual attack from the
enemy
folks how do we react to this right i
mean uh believe the vaccine said the
vaccine killed your immune system
believed that getting covet is a
spiritual attack from the enemy
suggested prayer
and ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine as
a treatment incredible damage potential
that this individual has done and now
he's dead of covet what's our reaction
i know people like the egg man feel
nothing but
uh pleasure at the fact that this
individual has died
um
i still have a very hard time gloating
about the death of anybody but i think
the message here is
not only was his message potentially
damaging to people who watched this
drivel
it may have also been what led to him
dying as well and um
maybe we leave it there maybe there
isn't more to say
but an another one of the you know and
it's it's emotionally exhausting it's
exhausting from a public health
standpoint but these anti-vaxxed
christians and right-wingers who have
media presences
they continue to die and it doesn't seem
like it's going to stop any time soon
hey this is really genuinely hilarious
tucker carlson bravely covered on his
program wednesday
the fact that cnn host brian stelter
fired his nanny because she wouldn't get
vaccinated now what's really really
funny about this segment first of all
why is tucker firing the personal
home staff decisions of hosts on other
networks i don't know he doesn't have
bigger and better things to do but the
really funny thing is in hearing the
leaked audio of brian stelter explaining
it brian stelter sounds eminently
reasonable i never have cared about
brian stelter now after hearing what he
did i'm like wow he really seems to be
thoughtful about what he's doing let's
let's get right into the segment and
take a listen to this is supposed to be
an indictment of brian stelter but i'm
thinking wow he really cares about his
kids so as we told you last night and
you may have noticed cnn pulled its
top-rated anchor chris cuomo off the air
for the crime of helping his brother but
you can't just pull someone off tv you
have to let people know ahead of time
otherwise you're going to have about a
dozen people tuning in and wondering
wait where's the steroid guy
so over now that's actually kind of
funny okay but now we'll go from chris
cuomo to brian stelton cena the dwarf
king dispatched his eunuch with the news
that chris cuomo was being pulled off
indefinitely suspended what's so
interesting and tells you so very much
about cnn is we learned today that the
eunuch himself would like chris cuomo's
job oh the betrayal mr barrier
by the way the eunuch i guess is his
nickname for brian stelter so
interesting so it raises the question
what kind of person is
cnn's media critic right we've come
across audio
that answers that question uh-oh so here
is and we're going to use his name for
the first time brian stelter
explaining to a group of people that he
has fired his nanny who of course
remains nameless because she refused to
get the injection to this
you know me and my wife both work
full-time we both make enough money to
have a nanny during the day
in new york
and uh and our nanny refuses to get
vaccinated and so we are parting ways
with her
and it was very very sad
that we thought we thought after six
months of seeing the vaccines are all
good and everybody's fine that she would
come around
he gave her six months guys it sounds
eminently reasonable brian stelter has a
nanny i don't know how many kids he has
um
he just says
i'm sure i could it doesn't matter
maybe the kids can get vaccinated maybe
not based on their age doesn't really
matter you want your kids to be spending
time around vaccinated people they
didn't even say to the nanny you gotta
get vaccinated today or you're gone
they gave the nanny six months of being
unvaccinated saying she'll come around
we like the nanny we don't want to get
rid of the nanny and she didn't come
around what on earth is the controversy
here and tucker carlson apparently
thinks this makes brian stelter look bad
so the headline here is that cnn's media
critic dismissed blithely dismissed his
little non-white servant because she
didn't obey now do we know that nanny
isn't white i don't know about that but
when he says blithely blithely means
it's casual and cheerful indifference
that is callous or improper
the audio says it was very sad and we
gave her six months we said okay we'll
get in the next six months once we know
everything that now we know about the
vaccines she'll come around and get and
she didn't
that doesn't sound blithely to me that
is quote very very sad
well how sad how sad was he exactly
doesn't sound blythe to me
did he pay her health insurance until
she finds a new job what is she doing to
eat and pay her rent now that she's been
dismissed by cnn's very sad media critic
we don't really care what happens to our
servants do we when they disobey so we
asked cnn today of course we got no
answer at all which is why would cnn
give tucker information about brian
stelter's privately hired nanny
what what did this is crazy this is a
story on tucker carlson if an answer
which is we don't know
we don't care
tells you a lot
what an insane story to be covering that
just really makes you wonder
what exactly is tucker carlson's real
issue here
with vaccines if there is one because my
belief is tucker carlson is smart enough
to realize
that as a decision it's a completely
reasonable decision particularly when
you give a six-month runway of saying
all right we don't like it but we do
like the nanny she's going to stick
around we're gonna give her six months
hopefully she'll get vaccinated she's
still not getting vaccinated we're gonna
have to part ways
i am sure
that privately tucker carlson knows that
that's completely reasonable there's no
way that he's so stupid as to think that
this is really the life act of an
individual but it is obvious that he is
completely captured by what his audience
expects him to be saying and that really
doesn't excuse what he's doing it really
doesn't but i think that that's really
the explanation because i have a very
hard time believing tucker is this
stupid and this story choice of course
the
the the nanny
of a host on a different network is a
story
imagine if i started coming here and
telling you guys about the things sam
cedar is doing with his large domestic
staff i'm making that up i don't i don't
know of any domestic staff that sam
cedar has but you all would rightly say
david what what exactly is the news here
what are you talking about and that's
exactly the reaction we should have with
tucker this is for clicks and it's
working it's working guys it's working
really really well for him
we're going to be doing this is so soon
now we are going to be doing the next
david the final of 2021 viewer town hall
all of you are welcome to call in and i
hope that you will here's the the
details
december 14th 6 pm eastern december 14th
6 pm eastern where will it be streaming
if you want to watch if you want to
watch
the town hall we'll stream on the pacman
live youtube channel that's the second
youtube channel
youtube.compacmanlife if you want to
participate in the town hall beautiful
everybody's welcome wide open we will
take calls via discord davidpakman.com
discord everyone's welcome we will also
have a priority channel on discord for
our website members so if you want your
shot at getting on to increase
dramatically
sign up at joinpackman.com not only will
you get the daily bonus show the
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show you will get a member-only
priority channel during the december
14th town hall let's take a quick break
we'll be back after this with quite a
program for you today
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
pakman the link is down below
welcome back to the david pakman show
remember that we are primarily supported
by viewers like you listeners like you
people who read the show maybe there are
transcripts you might just be a reader
who sign up for membership on our
website at
joinpakman.com i would love for you to
do so
and you'll get instant access to the
daily bonus show commercial free audio
and video streams of the show
priority access to the viewer town halls
like the one we have coming up on
december 14th at 6 00 p.m
etc etc all right let's hear from some
of you right now
um you can call in via the david pakman
show discord at davidpakman.com
discord
let's start today
with spiel
from nashville tennessee am i
pronouncing that correctly
hey yeah that's that's correct beautiful
what's on your mind today
um i guess uh
i just wanted to say
you know
does
like would democrats maybe losing
in 2022 or
say like republicans maybe gaining seats
in 2022 actually help
democrats
in 24 given the kind of swing cycle
of these elections i don't think so for
two different reasons number one
the whole swing nature of of these
elections is midterms after
the party and the white house changes in
the immediately previous election so
it's
it's not just it's all swings so it's
better in 24 for democrats if they lose
in 22 i don't know of any historical
data that would suggest that it's also
sort of accelerationist in a way the
idea that
by making things get worse you then
create circumstances in which things get
better and historically it's just not
worked that way like we've looked at
whether that's a thing and it really
isn't it's really been like the big
progressive gains have been made through
incremental progress and continuation
the progressive era late 19th century up
until about 1915
um civil rights era
the new deal era i took kind of
mentioned them out of order there so no
i don't i mean it's a totally reasonable
question to ask
um the only caveat to that spiel would
be
if
it's not about making things worse by
having republicans win in 22 or whatever
but if the perceived danger levels for
24 are higher for left-wing voters
because republicans win in 22 and then
it motivates them in some way maybe
there would be an argument to be made
there but overall i just think democrats
would be best served to do as well as
possible in 22 and then again in 24. i
wouldn't play these kind of back and
forth games with it
okay yeah that makes sense because i
feel like uh
yeah definitely you know
whatever
people or whatever can get democrats to
go out and vote more in 24 to me seems
like
uh most advantageous for democrats right
so thanks for taking my call man all
right thank you spiel from nashville uh
thank you so much
let's go next to steph from wisconsin
steph you were on the air
hey david uh thanks for calling on me
my pleasure
i have a question um
what are your thoughts on the new travel
restrictions in terms of people now
needing a test 24 hours in advance
well as before i believe it was
72 hours yeah i just i heard about this
because a friend of mine sent me a
message while we were filming the show
about it um he travels regularly and and
you know i've i i do too and i've had uh
i guess it's
three trips since the start of the
pandemic for which i've needed um return
tests to come back to the united states
i think it's very very problematic from
a logistical standpoint now i don't know
whether it will prevent disease from
spreading it may or it may not i really
don't know
from a logistical standpoint
it's actually very difficult right now
to get well first of all if you're
looking at a pcr test which is the most
accurate i don't know of any place where
you can get it guaranteed within 24
hours maybe there's some places but
especially in other parts of the world
it's very very tough which means that
you're going to be overwhelmingly
relying on antigen tests now the
anti-antigen test i don't know if you
heard my story from when i was in spain
in august but on the way back my
girlfriend had two false positive
antigen tests we ultimately went and got
a pcr but you know it took six hours to
find it and then another 24 to get the
result if we had been
with within 24 hours of the flight we
would have simply been stuck in spain
because of the less reliable
antigen tests so i i just logistically i
don't know how this is going to be
managed and when i read that i was
thinking it looks like i'm traveling
domestically for the foreseeable future
okay yep that that was exactly what i
was wondering in terms of the rapid
tests over the more reliable ones so
that answered it exactly thank you yeah
and you know in some airports like i
remember when i was flying through
frankfurt
you could get antigen tests and there
would be different prices for different
time like time windows but it was all
the same test so if it's like if you had
24 hours
then it was like 80 bucks and if you
needed it within six hours for a flight
it was 150 and if you needed it within
one hour you could pay like 350 but it
was all the same test and of course the
risk would be if you get a false
positive you're kind of screwed either
way you know
yeah yeah exactly
all right steph thank you for the call
very good question
all right there goes steph very good um
all right let's uh let's keep talking to
people why don't we maybe against my
better judgment let's go to eric from
cancun eric from cancun has delivered
some of the best calls we've ever had
and also some so atrocious i've had to
cut them early eric what's on your mind
today
um hi david and first i want to
apologize about the lesson with cole and
the thing is that it wasn't out of bad
faith it was out of not knowing how to
put my ideas into words i do apologize
for the last time we called
and
the thing i want to talk about can i
talk about my autism my asperger
if if you would like yeah and remember
you know we have a lot of people waiting
to chat so ideally if you have a
question that would be the ideal thing
okay
and i want to clear out the doubts of
antibacters because i want to tell you
that it doesn't cause autism the vaccine
i was born with it and here's some
symptoms with it it doesn't turn me into
a shape-shifting monster although i wish
to like beast boy and mystique from
x-men
adidas is that
i'm
i lack of some emotional
intelligence
and have you seen the movie have you
seen the big bang theory for and sheldon
unlike sheldon cooper
there's a guy where he goes to the door
and he knocks like this penny penny
penny and some aspects have some those
kind type of um
ticks then
we have some emotions
for example because i play the piano
sometimes i pretend to play the piano
when i hear a song i like
very literal
for example if you think of an electric
plan someone could think of a christmas
tree
it might be just me or maggie for mass
burgers but i'm also brutally honest
have you seen the movie liar liar
i have one
like in the movie like a liar that they
tell the truth with a filter
right
all right well very good eric i
appreciate you calling in and we always
love hearing from you
but trust me that if i say something
appropriate it's not out of bad faith
and i apologize if i i apologize if i do
well you've never said anything that i'm
aware of in bad faith eric thank you
okay i wish to call you soonly and tell
you more about other things all right
very good now one thing eric i i was
under the impression that we don't use
the term asperger's anymore because it
refers to a nazi doctor and so we just
say
low on the autism spectrum are you have
you heard of that
um no because
i do have asperger's and my psychos my
psychiatrist told me that it's okay if i
use that term okay um
all right very good eric thank you all
weather is good in cancun today
and is right now rainy and all year is
like a sauna but right now is like
in summer where you live are you in los
angeles right
no i will be in los angeles next week
actually but i'm in the northeast all
right eric thank you very much
appreciate the call we love hearing from
eric from cancun
and glad to hear that you are doing well
let's go next to sam in new york city
sam you were on the air
hey thanks for taking my call um i just
wanted to get your take on the potential
of reintroducing
um
uh what's it called um
earmarks into bills given like how
difficult it's been to
pass some of these major bills the
democrats have been trying to get
through congress and i understand the
potential to lead corruption but i feel
like earmark could be a good way to
get these bills uh past the
50
senate limit um nah i don't like it it's
you're making it a pyrrhic victory i
understand the idea
which is uh you know you start allowing
for more goodies in these bills and
you'll get people to support them but
i would i would consider it a pyrrhic
victory it would be a victory in which
you do so much damage that do you really
come out ahead uh i don't i don't like
it no i don't think we should go
backwards
even if it's like all right name some
[ __ ] after joe manchin for
i don't know
a lot of times those things aren't done
at the federal level anyway i'm not sure
it's it doesn't it doesn't strike me i
think the right way to do it is elect a
few more democrats you know
i guess my thought is that the marginal
cost
of an earmark is way less than the
benefits of passing some of these bills
overall so it's but i get what you're
saying if it is just a pure victory if
it's going to lead to something that's
sort of inadequate then of course
there's no point i mean the marginal
cost of one ear mark might be small but
you if you if you say let's just start
handing out earmarks again it's not
going to be just one that you're
exchanging for the bill it's going to be
dozens hundreds whatever you know
yeah i don't know anything else sam
no that's it i just want to get your
cake thanks so much all right appreciate
it there's sam from new york city
great to hear from you of course
let's go next to tanner from duluth
minnesota
um hello hello you're on the air
sweet do i sound good
beautiful audio i have to say
awesome thank you all right um
so
in minnesota um
a lot of uh
a lot of industry goes on here and stuff
like that and i was just wondering if um
you know if you noticed all the like
strikes and labor movement going on
right now do you really do you think
that um
democrats should be doing more to
support it or support unions because i
feel like you know um
back in decades ago like union people in
unions used to be like hardcore democrat
voters and now it seems like
unions kind of just kind of went by the
wayside and they don't really care about
him anymore and a lot of people in
unions actually vote republican now
especially like in the trades which used
to be like
very very blue yeah you're completely
right so in terms of the strikes and and
making progress in terms of labor i
think it's a perfect opportunity we have
seen
you know the pandemic has been basically
horrible in all ways but if we if we
want to say hey what are maybe some good
things to come from it one is the rapid
advancement of mrna technology for other
types of vaccines and now there's all
sorts of different advancement that's
happening there and it's created this
opportunity in the kind of shutdown and
then restarting in many industries for
workers to say hey you know we're going
to come back if and when we get better
conditions better pay etc so i think the
opportunity is an extraordinary one i
would like to see democrats be more
openly supportive of unions i also think
it's important to kind of couch the
union discussion
in proper context because there are some
people who say we i would like to see
every employee be part of a union you
know the truth is
with small businesses with very few
employees being an overwhelmingly
large portion of the work that is out
there
mom and pops with two three employees
etc
my opinion is that really doesn't lend
itself to unionization i think there are
other ways to empower workers there and
create a safe safety net and you know
some states have put in place paid
medical and family leave regardless of
employer size yeah i think they're so i
think our expectations have to be
reasonable that at the mom and pop level
unions are probably not the future of
democratizing labor there's other things
but yes i would like to see more
successes come from the strikes that we
are seeing i think the timing could not
possibly be better leverage is something
that has not been at this level for
workers for a really long time and i'd
like to see democratic uh elected
officials be more supportive for sure
totally sounds good
all right thanks tanner appreciate it
yeah thank you very much first time
caller love your show all right thank
you so much there's tanner from duluth
what a phone call what a phone call uh
let's take a very quick break but if
you're holding don't hang up because
we're gonna go right back to the phones
momentarily
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right let's go back to the phones
and hear from a few more people we take
calls via discord davidpakman.com
discord let's go to jordan in richmond
virginia jordan you're on the air
jordan in richmond please unmute
yourself so we can chat we'd love to
hear from you
and last opportunity for jordan i see
you're talking but you have muted
yourself or your mic isn't working so we
can't hear you
all right that's too bad jordan from
richmond was really hoping
that that would work let's go to
um is it isa from london is that right
issa
hey david how's it going man it's going
well
um
yeah i actually didn't think that you
would choose me so i guess i just want
to say thanks for covering
uh the written house trial it was pretty
pretty entertaining and informative as
well you know i honestly don't know much
about
u.s law so i was learning as well uh and
with your coverage and um the coverage
from your fans so
um
yeah thanks thanks for thanks for
covering that and that judge was a real
that judge was a real horror show why
didn't you think i would call on you i'm
curious
uh because i don't know i just there's
there's loads of people in the chat so
oh okay
yeah all right what now tell me this i
appreciate that was the entire vigilante
militia scene that was the context of
the trial insane to you as a person
who's in london
yeah it was because you know obviously
we don't have guns or anything
so the whole idea of especially a kid
who's underage at the time just
picking up
some gun from his armory and just
running around playing call of duty that
that's just
like you you you never hear of that like
as an english person you will never hear
something like this in your lifetime
ever so
that was that was crazy that's
interesting so like for you is it even
hard to say
well i guess like so as you watch the
trial
were you most interested in the specific
defense or just the general context in
which all of this was taking place
you know when i was coming in i was
interested in the whole thing but
as i was watching the trial i became
more and more interested in kyle's
defense
and i was you know this might sound a
bit controversial and i'm not
by saying this i'm not saying that i
support kyle in any way whatsoever yeah
but i was
honestly i was drawn to his defense
lawyers and the way they worked honestly
because i i think they they took full
advantage of the judge you know with the
whole uh pixelated video thing oh yeah
and you know asking for a mistrial over
and over again i i was just i was drawn
to the way they were working honestly
yeah it was definitely compelling to see
yeah no no question about it um all
right thank you so much for your
perspective i appreciate it
all right take care
uh there is issa from london
let's go
next
there's a lot of people wanting to get
on today very interesting folks oh let's
go to our friend scott from pensacola
who you we've spoken before right scott
scott from pensacola you're on the air
if you unmute yourself
oh boy emma you got me yet yes now
you're on
all right
excellent um so the question i've got
today is
what do you think
uh
the general public can kind of do as far
as people that are concerned with uh the
way things are going with some of these
school board meetings
and the potential for violence with some
of them oh if it's so tough because
saying that the answer is to show up to
counter the wacky school board people is
only likely to trigger them more and
maybe even likely to cause violence in
and of itself
because these people are so volatile so
it's very tough to say i mean i i
one idea that's been suggested is that
there's a temporary hiatus of public
comment at school board meetings but my
instinct is never to suppress speech and
i don't know about you scott but my
instinct is that that's not how i want
to fix a problem so it's very very tough
i mean maybe
there need to be more strictly enforced
rules of decorum at these school board
meetings i don't know but it's become a
mess
yeah i definitely agree with you i think
that if we were to
limit speech at those sorts of things it
could end up with a slippery slope yeah
and some unintended consequences
i mean i think that one thing
maybe is that the people who act out
like children at the they're adults
legally but they act like children
they really should be shamed and
humiliated in their communities i mean
my instinct is that sometimes people go
up like a rem we played a video of a
girl and her dad who both quoted hitler
in their opposition to masks and people
in the crowd cheered and so if those
folks were ostracized and humiliated in
their communities my guess is they'd be
less likely to do this stuff but they're
not going to be ostracized and
humiliated when half the community seems
to agree with them you know
and then they'll just cry cancel culture
if that happens anyway yeah yeah no it's
a tough question but it's wacky what's
going on
all right well thanks for your time
david hey listen before you go is the
gulf breeze pensacola bridge finally
reopened or what's going on down there
so the gulf breeze pensacola bridge is
open
for
two lanes in each direction
so for those who don't know during
hurricane sally
some barges that were used by the
construction company got loose and
damaged the bridge and it was shut down
and everybody had to take a toll road
um around and it really ruined traffic
around here for about nine months yeah i
mean didn't it
didn't it make what can be a 15-minute
trip like a 75-minute trip by having to
drive all the way around
yeah if you had to go all the way around
yes yeah you get to downtown pensacola
there were a lot of businesses that uh
suffered on both sides of the bridge
so
hopefully
um
the litigation that's involved with that
will will make some things right yeah
yeah we have friends down there who live
in gulf breeze and work in downtown
pensacola and it was just a complete and
total mess i i kind of liked pensacola i
have to tell you i know it's like it is
sort of the deep south it's not miami
beach you know
um but i actually had a good time the
food scene wasn't bad there's some place
called like the is it the something
grill downtown mediterra blue something
does that ring a bell
uh not off the top of my head my
favorite restaurant's gonna be the grand
marlin out on pensacola beach oh grand
marlin yeah there was a you know where i
went when i was there i went to joe
paddy's
ah nice yeah got some great crab brushes
you can get yeah yeah absolutely anyway
hope to make it down there again glad to
hear the bridges reopened
all right thanks david okay very good uh
there we go there's scott from pensacola
working with a little bit of a delay but
we did the absolute best we could with
it um you can only do so much with it
you know that's that's the reality
let's go next to
um oh where are we going there's so many
interesting callers let's go to louie
from new brunswick louie you're on the
air
hey good afternoon david can you hear me
i can hear you fine
so i really enjoy your show for some
caller long time listener uh my wife and
i find ourselves in a strange situation
okay we we we're uh
part of a
a church that's very very right-leaning
uh but politically we're the opposite
except for some key issues we feel like
we have to almost keep it under wraps um
our political
uh bent
but um
we really have a hard time discussing
uh just just common issues with our you
know with our brothers and sisters uh
have you have you ever encountered
anything like this before and
what do you do yeah i mean i guess in
some sense i have in that
there i mean listen i'm not a religious
jew i'm culturally jewish ethnically
jewish culinarily jewish i'm not
religious but
there are people in my circles who are
more religiously
devout jews
and they have much more culturally
conservative views but it's not really
become a problem it's just like i know
those are their views and they know my
views let me ask what what denomination
or what is this is this a christian
church
it is it's a christian church where
basically non-denominational
uh and the funny thing is that our
congregation is becoming extremely
multicultural i'll give you a quick
example
we had a
a christmas
uh well it's an advent children's
concert i would like to say and
i want to say 90 of the children were
uh non-white
okay and it was a great sight like i i
you know our our leadership is saying
things like
look if our if our community is very
multicultural then the church should
represent that right so i love that i
love that however i've noticed that um
a lot of the the men in the leadership
uh or i would say not the leadership a
lot of the men who are very engaged uh
are are a lot more i would say caucasian
and then skew heavily towards
i hate to say this but trumpism well i
mean let me just ask you what what
what's like a big issue on which you
disagree with the general position of
the church
um well well that's just like there it's
not a position of the church to to to
follow politics but um
but but when a lot of people you know
are like
just spouting uh things that they heard
on fox news and worse like uh
newsmechs yeah it's really it's really
horrible like for example we were in a
prayer meeting and someone was like like
praying against nancy pelosi it was like
it was literally like a fox news talking
point now in a situation i mean listen i
don't know anything about churches but
in a situation like that couldn't you
stand up and say listen guys
um
it's not appropriate for us to be
involving politics in this way i'm not
making a statement for or against anyone
i'm just saying this is a place for
faith and community not for politics
like could could you say that or would
that not be well received
well uh we have said that actually in
our men's meeting we've made a point
that like we shall not ever talk
politics because it it's so divisive
right and
uh and when i've confronted people
one-on-one about say like hypocrisy of
trump or like that he lies or he's like
uh
you know he's abused women or done
horrible things i've noticed that it it
hurts people's feelings and like they
record they recoil like they were uh you
know personally injured
so so my wife and i have learned like
just not even to bring it up and we just
cringe and kind of like just hold our
tongue when when things come up could
you find a more liberal church i mean is
that an option i mean i i understand
it's a big deal to change churches i'm
sure but but is it to the point where
you would say i want to find a different
church well it's funny that you bring
that up because a lot of people who have
spoken about this outside the church say
stuff like that like why don't you leave
dude like why are you still there
and and you know what it is is like
there's so much love there's so much
relationships we've been there for over
10 years we feel like we feel like
um
it would be like abandoning that it's
just not an option it's worth it i think
just to like stay in the labor of love
and like just see how things turn out
well in that case it sounds like you
have your answer as to what to do right
yeah yeah you're right yeah we're
staying yeah yeah yeah you sound pretty
pretty confident about that all right
well let me know how it goes and by the
way i mean listen
you're not saying that from the pulpit
they're doing politics right because
that's actually against the church
charter for non-profits
right no they're not there there's even
when even when trump was like flying
high and things were like uh you know in
in their perspective because now it's
the opposite like you know it's it's
almost like a shame now i think for even
for trump is to talk about trump but
um or to defend him i should say but
even when when he was flying high i
would say like early in his uh
in his administration yeah
there were times where i have a feeling
that the pastor crossed the line and
people had to talk to him and say you
need to you need to dial that back like
oh you can't yeah so it's a struggle
especially with the older
the older generation i would say like
over 50 over 60. got it got it all right
we'll keep us posted on how it goes yeah
thanks louie louie from new brunswick
dealing uh that's quite a matzo ball
hanging out there that he's dealing with
proverbially of course i know it's a
christian uh a christian church um all
right let's go next to
mike from massachusetts mike you're on
the air
how are you doing today david i'm doing
well
good to hear um i got two questions if
we can go if we have the time please uh
first and if you've already spoken about
this on your show and i missed it i
apologize for the repetition um what do
you make of
what's going on in
austria with their nationwide mandate
and that other countries in europe are
starting to inch towards doing the same
thing
do you
like a nationwide vaccine mandate i mean
do you see that as simply a step too far
for western democracy or is it kind of
or do you feel like maybe we've reached
a point where
the extreme circumstances will
uh require extreme solutions listen here
here's my view right uh dire
circumstances require extreme solutions
um my view is is as follows i'm trying
to think about this as pragmatically as
possible my opinion on this is heavily
biased by the fact
that it's not going to happen in the
united states so when someone says to me
do you think it's too far or not might
it happen the united states is not going
to have a literal vaccine mandate where
the government says you must be
vaccinated they're doing stuff through
employers osha employers must test or
but it's just not going to happen and so
because i see that it's just kind of a
non-starter
it's hard for me to say it would be the
right or the wrong thing necessarily i
mean i think it is morally defensible
at the same time i think there are good
arguments
legally speaking for why it can be a
work requirement it can be a school
requirement it can be a requirement to
avail yourself of certain types of
businesses but just a straight-up
mandate it's i don't know legally
whether it would stand in a completely
broad-based federal way
although there's people on both sides of
that i think my issue at this point is
what is most likely to most quickly get
us out of the pandemic and by that i
mean to an endemic phase it doesn't seem
like it's going to go away
and um
it is about convincing the people we can
convince to go and get vaccinated
uh and also
to some degree it's about the reality
that we don't interact with everyone
like the fact that there's a big
anti-vaxx community in mississippi
is statistically very unlikely to affect
my exposure to the virus sure i might be
on a plane with folks but for the most
part it's like what's going on in my
kind of more immediate community travel
spreads etc etc but i'm trying to focus
more on sort of like what can i do
within my immediate community and so to
go back to your question do i think it's
right or wrong what austria is doing
i don't fully know everything that's
taking place in austria
but it's not for me to say that they are
right or wrong for doing it this is what
they're doing i don't think it's going
to happen in the united states so my
concern is how can we get beyond the
pandemic phase given that there's not
going to be a full-on vaccine mandate
that's i'm thinking pragmatically
so i agree with you that it's extremely
unlikely to happen at the federal level
um that would be a very big uphill
battle for any administration to take on
but
do you see
do you see a certain point where maybe
states might try to impose a statewide
vaccine i really don't i really don't
like being held by the supreme court in
the past yeah i know it has and there's
this very important case from cambridge
massachusetts and i think it was 1903
that people point to as precedent i
think that republican governors would
never do it and democratic governors
realize it would be politically
problematic so i don't think we're even
going to see a mandate at the state
level i could be wrong if i'm wrong i'll
eat my socks you know
fair enough um all right switch gears to
a second question i'll just try to keep
things moving
um so this is this might be purely
opinion oriented at this point but so
the supreme court is hearing
the missouri abortion case today at
least is hearing arguments on it um and
i've been here i've been trying to do my
own research and look into what
certain experts think about what is
gonna happen and the opinions are all
over the map uh
you know some people think that
this should be so obvious that it's
unconstitutional that the mere fact that
they're hearing it is a bad sign yes um
but then there are you know there are
conservatives who are like the supreme
court always lets us down it's not it's
going to be the same case this time so
and obviously that's not me saying let
down but that's the conservative saying
that they get let down
i mean do you what's your opinion on how
this is all going to shake out i mean
are we looking at the end of roe v wade
or is this going to get shot down and
servers are going to freak out again i
have no idea i really don't i co it's
it's i've read some of the same stuff
you've read it sounds like and i don't
even bother making a prediction because
it's so unclear it's sort of a wacky
supreme court it's strange times i think
anything could happen i do think that if
one of these really strict laws is
upheld by the supreme court it is the
beginning of the end for roe v wade but
as far as what is going to happen i have
no idea we're just gonna have to wait
and see
okay
um fair enough all right thank you for
taking my call all right mike from
massachusetts thank you so much for the
call
appreciate everybody we were able to
speak to that's going to do it for today
but we will take calls again soon and
remember december 14th at 6 p.m will be
a wide open viewer town hall where
everyone is welcome to call in more on
that upcoming
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to
patreon.com david pakman show where you
can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
david pakman show all right let's get
into the mailbag even including a
thanksgiving
greetings from some
i guess unexpected people maybe
depending on your perspective um from
last week
if you want to have a chance at
participating in the mailbag you can
email info davidpakman.com i do want to
say this again because unfortunately
we're dealing more and more with this
if you're emailing every day
we're probably no longer seeing your
messages when people email in too much
and there are people sending messages
multiple times a day
we're there there's no chance you're
going to be in the mailbag the emails
are just auto auto uh
sort of filtered
into a folder and um
you know let's
quality over quantity let's keep it
there info davidpakman.com let's go
right into the first one which is
you're a loser and a racist and of
course almost mandatory
that your
which is supposed to be you are
contracted to you apostrophe re
misspelled as y-o-u-r
my loser and a racist doesn't make a lot
of sense i don't know when it became law
that when you write hate mail you have
to put in the wrong you're
um but certainly we are seeing that very
strongly in our email bag so you're a
loser and a racist thank you
thomas wrote in about socialism this is
a good email actually thomas writes
your remarks seem to indicate that the
us doesn't have socialism if we take the
broad definition the u.s has plenty
social security medicare minimum wages
etc and more than enough government
support for large industries a socialism
that predates that for the majority
one political party has been trying for
decades to eradicate socialism for 70 to
80 percent of the people which would
leave more wealth to shovel up to the
plutocracy if we don't take the broad
meaning of the word shouldn't we also
drop the broad meaning of capitalism
vulture capitalism vampire capitalism
mom and pop operations etc
corporations and the financial behemoths
that use wealth of the capital class to
rake more of it up for them a lot of
really good points here in points that
we've made
when when i say the united states is not
a socialist country
what i mean is that at the top level
socialism including a socialized
ownership of the means of production is
not the model
thomas is completely correct that in
certain areas
we do have
socialized services
and you can even include more
police in most places some places have
like sort of like private police forces
but police in most places
fire fighters in most places
uh social security is a socialization of
sorts
uh medicare yes we we have the military
um and so
when we say we are not a socialist
country
we mean one thing about it we mean when
the right says
it's socialist to
have obama phones as uh jesse lee
peterson once told me or whatever this
is not a socialist country or government
at the top level but we have socialist
elements within it uh for sure
next email is from bruce
bruce says david what i'm wondering is
when is elon musk going to hop on one of
these bee arks that he is creating
and going to crash into venus which is
the planet he wants the earth to become
yeah um there's a lot more
anti-elon musk sentiment in the email
lately
um
and i did a if you're interested in in
the topic of elon musk and tesla from
the electric vehicle standpoint on
friday on black friday i did a stream
where we did a lot of different things
but one of the things is i did talk
about my increased
it's not dissatisfaction but
less enthusiasm about tesla as the
future of electric vehicles i think
tesla was a an early mover
and when it comes to the range of their
vehicles they're second to none but
there are other companies including
general motors audi
just about all of them that are
generally speaking better at building
vehicles
and i talked about where i believe
tesla is going to start having problems
it's less about the personality call
around elon musk but if you're
interested in that topic check out
that live stream from black friday very
very powerful live stream
um okay here's a thanksgiving greeting
maybe you guys did not expect
on uh thursday thanksgiving i got a
email
an email
from jimmy from philly that furious
angry trumpist who calls in
and he said simply happy thanksgiving
there was no attack
there was no insult there was no slur or
the homophobia or transphobia
that we've come to expect from jimmy
from philly simply happy thanksgiving he
does email me sometimes
uh just um
just to say hello so not sure how many
of you are surprised by that
but i did receive that
next question is from jeff jeff wright
in writes in and says why the big
microphone david sir
i see people online using tiny lavalier
mics and they sound fine
or those that wrap around your face
i know this is a stupid question but why
do you use such a big mic at least it
doesn't obscure your mouth like other
youtubers i hope you're not compensating
for anything big fan and website member
yet you know i've talked about this
before
there's a couple different reasons that
i've stuck with the big mic
when we years ago when we tried the
clip-on lavalier mics
we didn't have the ones that sounded
that good so i'm completely open to
switching to a lav mic
if someone can recommend to me one that
really will sound as good as one of
these larger condenser microphones but
a lot of people just listen to this show
via the audio podcast
i don't want to have damaged sound
quality that's one reason the second
reason is our main studio is very well
treated from the standpoint of
echo and uh deadening the room and all
of that stuff
our backup studio which we now have is
not
and using a lavalier mic when i've
tested it is insanely echoey and when
traveling i've got some travel upcoming
where i'm going to be doing the show
from different locations it's so
unpredictable what the room
treatment is going to be you might be
you know in a could be a hotel room with
those kind of like padded
almost like it's just it's like a
painting but it's just padded fabric you
know it's kind of like in now
which helps to deaden the sound and
carpets and whatever or it can be really
echoey because it's so unpredictable the
large canister microphone just seems to
sound better but if someone can
recommend a good love that really will
will perform well
in all of these scenarios i will switch
to it trust me when i travel and i bring
the big boy
i think every time it would be great to
have a tiny little microphone all right
jeff so i hope that's a comprehensive
enough answer
this is a very sad email from matthew
matthew says
conspiracy theory aunt or he's from new
york so i guess he would say ant
i'm matthew from new york
my whole family is diverse republican
members trumpists trump haters
don't like the rhetoric but will vote
for policies and just classic republican
members but all as i know vaccinated
except one my aunt
she has conspiracy theories about the
vaccine and the left so much
that she thinks trump is saying get the
vaccine
as a reverse psychology technique i
don't know what to do i don't want to
cut off but i'm feeling i feel like i'm
enabling her every time i talk to her
about politics what do i do you know i
get these questions all the time i can't
tell you matthew what to do
you have to decide what is the
emotional psychological mental health
impact
of being in contact with someone who is
so disconnected from reality versus how
much do you value the relationship with
her and what effect it would have to cut
her off
in terms of the relationships between
you and other people in the family i
can't answer that question for you what
i think is very interesting about this
particular conspiracy theory
is that it's an example of an in you
it's indefeasible it's unfalsifiable
right
because
if trump were to say don't get the
vaccines
a lot of these folks would say see
trump is saying don't get it
and if trump says get it
anyone like matthew's aunt can say it's
reverse psychology what he really is
wanting people to do is not to get it
even though he's saying that you should
get it so
that's any kind of unfalsifiable claim
like that is very very tough because no
matter what he says
they come to the same conclusion so i
don't really have advice on the personal
thing but it is a very tough conspiracy
theory to deal with
next message came in via facebook
i don't suppose you would be interested
to hear or see this but the restaurants
in my town have started to put let's go
brandon on the bottom of tickets i
figured you know what it means
guy mon oklahoma pub on the bricks yeah
i've seen reports of this where
you go you know oftentimes at
restaurants
the receipt
has some kind of message at the bottom
sometimes it's thank you for your
business happy holidays
thank you for coming we appreciate you
stuff like that there are some
restaurants that have started to put at
the very bottom of the rest of the
restaurant receipt let's go brandon
which is of course code for f joe biden
it's one of the cringiest new right-wing
phrases which they think is super clever
and it's not um i wouldn't go to such a
restaurant if i ever saw that at the
bottom of
a receipt i would never go back
uh
everybody's got to decide for themselves
what to do
last one coming in via twitter
this user says david pakman
you seem to suffer from a pretty severe
case of autism
that has only intensified over the years
it's hilarious that you'd call anyone a
doofus referring to the judge in the
written house case it's hilarious that
you'd call anyone a doofus how hard were
you bullied growing up or were you just
socially awkward
to the point of becoming socially
crippled
very very big shot across the bow
of course if anybody knew about my first
jobs which i've talked about here on the
show
uh
which were very very much
sales oriented
dependent on rapidly
reading social cues and
building rapport with people you've just
met
you might come away with a different
conclusion but a very interesting
response here
to me saying that written house judge
was wacky wasn't he so congratulations
to everybody who got their messages into
the mailbag today you can write in
info
davidpakman.com
you might notice all of the emails that
get on our one paragraph so the
multi-page emails as much time as may
have gone into them which we appreciate
very much they're not going to make it
onto the mailbag and we have a fantastic
bonus show coming up for you today sign
up at joinpacman.com you will get access
to the bonus show instantly as well as
the commercial free audio and video
feeds of the show we will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman